PETER HODGSON: I'm Pete Hodgson.
I'm an interaction
designer working
on the Google Assistant.
Over the next few
minutes, I'm going
to give you a brief overview
of one of the key topics core
to conversation design.
That's conversational repair.
People historically don't
much like voice interfaces
because of the
feeling it gives them
when the conversation
takes a misstep.
Research shows that
60% of all users
feel either angry or confused,
or awkward and self-conscious,
in general, because they feel
like they did something wrong.
After all, our
instinct is to assume
that the other party
in the conversation
is being cooperative.
So it must be us that's
doing something wrong.
The good news is that
69% of the same group
are likely to give the voice
interface another go even when
something has just gone wrong.
So if we can make a
conversation work well
when it takes a
misstep, then there's
a great opportunity to build
user trust and confidence
in the assistant.
It's tempting to describe
these misstep situations
as error cases, which
suggests that the user has
done something wrong.
But it's important to
remember that the users know
what they want.
There's no such thing as a
voice query without an intent.
For example, the user
might be being ambiguous.
Perhaps their
intent is unspoken,
and they've implied an intent,
which we haven't covered
in the recognition grammars.
Maybe they're just poking
around and trying things out.
Remember, discovery
is an intent.
Poking around is an intent.
And figuring out the boundaries
of a piece of technology
is also an intent.
But mostly, people
are being co-operative
and want to do something,
even if they didn't say so
explicitly.
And it's our job
to figure out what
they're trying to do, and to
move the conversation forward.
Just because their query
doesn't match our expectations,
doesn't mean it's an error.
For example, let's talk
about a no input state.
When the assistant
prompts for a reply
it opens the microphone
for a short period of time,
listening for a response.
If there's no spoken
input detected
within a number of
seconds, the assistant
closes the microphone again
and will re-prompt the user.
It's easy to label
this situation
as a single type of error based
on a technical description.
But there are many reasons
why the user might not
reply to a prompt before
the microphone is closed.
They might have been distracted
or changed their minds.
Or perhaps the options presented
don't match their expectations.
Or they simply
hesitated too long.
In each of these
cases, the assistant
might say something
slightly different,
depending on the context.
So it's important to
consider the possible context
of every repair case, since
they can change the language
and structure of re-prompts.
Conversational repair
is a big topic.
And we can't cover everything
in this short video.
So in the next few
minutes I just want
to focus on three main
types of repair cases.
First, there's no match inputs.
This is when the assistant
has heard something
that doesn't match
the recognition
grammars for a specific state.
Then there's no
inputs, as I just
described, when the assistant
has prompted for a response,
but heard nothing
back from the user.
And then there's
disambiguation, where the system
has a confident
but partial match
and needs more specific
information to progress.
So here's an example
conversation with these three
repair cases shown.
[INAUDIBLE] just
sending a message.
Let's run through it.
SPEAKER 1: Hey, Google.
Send a message.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sure.
Who do you want to message?
SPEAKER 1: Hey, Hon.
Can you turn down
the TV, please?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Who
do you want to message?
SPEAKER 1: David.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Which David?
Is it David Singh,
David J, or David Brown?
SPEAKER 1: David Brown.
PETER HODGSON: The
first misstep is
when the Assistant
has the mic open,
and the grammars are listening
for a specific contact name.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sure.
Who do you want to message?
SPEAKER 1: Hey, Hon.
Can you turn down
the TV, please?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Who
do you want to message?
PETER HODGSON: This
is a no match case.
Since it's the first
time in this conversation
that the assistant hasn't
understood the user,
we will try the lightest touch
repair in much the same way
as we would a natural human
to human conversation.
It's the equivalent of
saying, huh, say that again.
We call this a rapid re-prompt.
The second case is when the
assistant hits a disambiguation
state.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Who
do you want to message?
SPEAKER 1: David.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Which David?
PETER HODGSON: It has
a confident match,
but it's ambiguous.
The input matches more
than one contact name,
so prompts for more
specific information.
As this is the first
repair in a disambiguation,
we might also treat
it quite lightly.
After all, the user knows their
contacts and who they meant.
The assistant just needs
a bit more information.
And the third repair
is a no input time out.
After the last prompt, the
user hasn't said anything.
Or the assistant hasn't
picked up the user's speech.
They may have left the room
or missed the question.
But the system is still
in a disambiguation state.
So the strategy here is
to help the user make
a choice by escalating
the detail in the prompt.
In this case, it's by
presenting the specific Davids
from [INAUDIBLE] contacts list.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Is it David
Singh, David J, or David Brown?
SPEAKER 1: David Brown.
PETER HODGSON: So here
are those cases again.
In a multi-step
conversation, every time
the assistant prompts
for a response,
the conversation designer
needs to consider all
of these possible repair cases.
The goal is to always move
the conversation forward
as naturally as possible.
But we can't keep
reprompting forever.
So we've got to consider the
maximum number of attempts that
are reasonable in
each conversation,
and provide ways out
of the conversation
when we reach that limit.
And remember, if we
have to keep on asking,
then the chances are
we've got something wrong.
The user is most probably
trying to be cooperative.
It's up to us to help them out.
So depending on each case,
the conversation designer
and engineers need to decide
the maximum number of tries
the assistant will prompt
the user before ending
the conversation.
And at that point, how it
will end the conversation.
SPEAKER 1: OK, Google.
Book a ticket to the ISS.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sure.
Which carrier are
you orbiting with?
SPEAKER 1: Honey, what
carrier were we looking at?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Which carrier?
SPEAKER 1: Honey?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
To make a booking,
I'll need to know which
carrier you're orbiting with.
For example, NASA or SpaceX.
Or you can say cancel.
SPEAKER 1: What?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Since I'm
having trouble understanding,
go ahead and tap a carrier
name on the screen.
PETER HODGSON: So in
this case, the Assistant
has tried three times to
get the name of the carrier
without getting a
recognizable answer.
That means the system
had to manage three
no match cases, one
after the other.
What you've heard is
one example of how
you might construct a repair
strategy for this case.
And we can break
it down like this.
No match one is treated
as a rapid re-prompt.
In no match two, we're
escalating the detail
in the prompt to clarify
the type of things we're
expecting the user to say.
We've also provided the
user with an escape option,
in case they've
changed their minds
or just want to stop
the conversation.
By no match three, we could
just end the conversation.
Or alternatively, we
can give the users
the option to make
an explicit input
by using the touch screen.
But remember, for all
conversational repair
prevention is better than cure.
An iterative design process
and formative user research
around the user's
expected language
will inform your design
of the most likely things
that users will
say at any point.
And, as a result, a
highly relevant set
of grammars for each
step of the conversation
can significantly improve
the user experience
and reduce the number
of repair cases.
I've just touched on a
couple of examples here.
And I want to reiterate,
it's important to recognize
that every conversation will
warrant its own strategy.
If you want to find out more
about conversational repair,
I highly recommend you visit
Google's new conversation
design guidelines.
And check out the other
videos on conversation design
in this series.
Thanks for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]